so you know the one of the things I
wanted to ask you about is uh obviously
you were one of the early Pioneers in
SAS and
Cloud um got to
profitability uh and ran the company you
know uh I think to be profitable but I I
saw you had this once.com where you you
have a new mission to for people to pay
for software once explain because you
you always come up with some ideas that
sometimes are quick sotic sometimes
they're brilliant sometimes they work
sometimes they don't explain
on.com sure so the history is we were
one of the earliest SAS companies Bas
cam was launched in 2014 we didn't even
have the SAS term back then yeah and at
that time SAS was just amazing it was
amazing because running your own
software was a total pain in the ass um
it was licenses and it was installations
and it was system requirements it was
all that stuff so everyone was so
excited when SAS comes out oh I just had
to fill in a form and I can use a piece
of software amazing and we jumped on
that and have been running base camp and
a ton of other services hey.com on new
email service SAS businesses 20 plus
years but one of the things I love is
this idea of the pendulum swinging right
we go from client to Ser server back to
client back to server many times over
the uh history of computing we've gone
from one extrem to the other I think
it's time for that pendulum to swing at
least a little bit back towards you
being able to buy a software product
rather than buying a software service
and that's our thesis with once that
there is a category of software where it
just does not make sense to pay on a
monthly basis for it and to pay out the
nose for something that is essentially a
commodity that's sort of the two-part
play one here being this is about price
this is about subscription fatig and
then the second part of it is also about
commoditization we have a bunch of
collaboration tools for example
information systems that just the
Innovation is gone like problems are
solved and when that happens in almost
any other domain someone Pioneers a new
product or service they get the market
for themselves for a few years and then
at some point competition moves in and
that's how capitalism is supposed to
work we're supposed to have competition
we're supposed to have Alternatives and
we're supposed to have generics so
that's the thesis with one we're going
to make a series of software products
that you can install run on your own
servers but is essentially web apps um
think WordPress that's one of the most
successful software products out there
if you look at total websites running on
the internet I think it's like 40% of
allnet websites run WordPress and it
runs in that model you download a piece
of software you set it up on your own
little server and what really connects
me to that mission is this idea that
this is what the internet was supposed
to be SAS unfortunately to some extent
helped the centralization of the
internet first it was just like oh
everyone is going to run their version
of base camp or hey on our computers
it's just going to be one set of service
even if we have hundreds of thousands of
customers they're all just running on
our computer so if our computer goes
down base camp goes down for 100,000
customers now we have five nines of
uptime so it's not been a problem for us
but generally speaking this idea that we
have centralization on top of that now
we have Cloud centralization so when AWS
us e one goes down about a third of the
internet goes offline with it right
that's not what darpet designed that's
not the internet that I fell in love
with the internet I fell in love with
was we can all run our own stuff I
remember running websites back in the
90s I just run it on my own box if my
friend's web server went down it had no
impact on mine at all so I think there's
just a lot of these Dynamics where we
knew some truths when the internet got
started that we kind of sort of forgot
or we gave him up for some conveniences
that make sense at a time but no longer
do now I'm not saying SAS is like
totally over every piece of SAS software
is going to be a product now I am saying
though I think there's a surprising
amount of SAS businesses that could be
product businesses instead and that if
you make that jump the cost structure is
completely different which means the
pricing structure can be completely
different which means that you can now
have competition in areas where you
really couldn't before one of the ones
we like to call out is slack right um I
asked uh uh Toby uh my friend and CEO at
Shopify hey uh Toby what are you what
are you paying for a slack and he was
like oh dude don't even don't even get
me so millions millions right millions
of year on recurring Revenue to use this
SAS service that's a commodity I mean
slack hasn't innovated in a long time I
think since um well unless you called
that redesign they just did that
everyone hated
Innovation it's just Pi up about per
force this is the natural life cycle of
startups this is what happens this is
not necessarily good or bad or whatever
it's just that this is an example of a
piece of software that should be
commoditized but it's difficult to do if
you're going to go up against something
like SAS right like what you're going to
price it like 20% cheaper or you g to
add 5% more features that's a tough
competition to go up against when you
have something entrenched but imagine if
I could go to Topia and say hey do you
know what that slack Bill instead of you
paying Millions every year what about
you just pay me like a thousand dollars
once all of a sudden super disruptive
yeah exactly you're dealing with orders
of magnitude difference and I think
that's what's possible because like I
can't out compete slack on operations
for example it takes a lot of people to
run SAS software it's actually still
complicated to have millions of users
you need a lot of operations people you
need sophisticated setup all this stuff
in the meantime all these computers have
gotten so much faster so much cheaper
you can now run so much more software on
your own but I think it hasn't clicked
and this is what often happens in in
technology same thing like iPhone comes
out and we go like oh a phone I don't
know what we're going to use this with
five years later everyone has figured
out exactly what to use this with we
have all this Innovation and I think
we're a little bit in that space right
now with what's been happening with
computers how fast they've actually
gotten just in the last five six seven
years how much scale you can have on
even the laptop I use for my development
is f than all my cloud computing um you
have an M3 I assume you got the
M3 M3 was like 16 cores I'm running like
my tests faster than what we're paying
astronomical bills to run continuous
integration in the cloud there's just
there's something going on there's
something in the water I think something
is brewing and we're going to we're
going to give it a try now ironically
slack is an example of us being early
like we had slack in 2005 it was called
campfire yep and we were just like a
decade too early in 2005 and there wasat
and there was uh what was the one that
um it wound up getting bought by
atlassian maybe that was hipat I think
it was hipchat yeah yeah I mean there
were competitors and now I guess Discord
is too early they were too early there
needs to be an open source or you know
thousand dollar and have as many people
you want on the server because yes what
what they've done now is like I have a
slack for my Founders All the
Investments we've made it's got 700
people in it and and they're like we
want $8 a purse in a month $100 a person
I'm like I'm not paying you whatever
this is going to wind up being $70,000 a
year that's insane for just our Founders
to talk to each other so if there was
one for $700 or even $77,000 I would
actually pay because I can't get the
archives and then I would pop it on a
server and run it yes uh and all these
clouds are so cheap I mean I it is
amazing your point though about what's
happened with silicon like this m this I
have the M2 MacBook Air with a like a
terabyte SSD and like 16 gigs of RAM I
cannot believe that for whatever it is
$1,500 or
$1,800 this their entry level computer
is absurd it is absurd uh how much power
it is listen selling software is hard
enough right now man it's hand toand
combat out there in B2B land the last
thing you need to do is slow your sales
team down because you don't have your
sock 2 dialed in so if you're SAS or a
services company and you store consumer
data in the cloud you know what you need
to do you need to check out vanta
they're going to get your sock 2
complying easier and faster and vanta
makes it so easy to get and renew your
sock 2 on average vanta customers are
sck to comply in just two to four weeks
compare that to 3 to 5 months without
vanta they're going to save you hundreds
of hours of work and up to 85% on
compliance cost and vanta does more than
just sock 2 they also automate up to 90%
compliance for gdpr Hippa and more you
can't afford to lose out on those major
customers the lighthouse customers the
Big Fish the whales because it's silly
stuff like locking compliance just work
with vanta I'm an investor in the
company it's a great company get your
compliance automated get it tight tight
as right and close those big deals
here's the best part V's going to give
you a thousand off because they love
this weekend startups they love startups
v.com twist that's
v.com twist to get $1,000 off your sock
too